[Music]
dr. it's a pleasure to meet you
thank you for making the trip out here
I'm excited to talk to you well great to
talk to yuge I had our mutual friend
Joel Kahn on the show a couple months
ago he was out here and he was singing
your praises I was familiar with your
work but he just went on and on and on
and that created quite an impact with
the audience so there's been a lot of
anticipation and excitement about you
sharing your wisdom with excellent
doctor
yeah he's very cool so so many things to
talk about I think probably the best way
to approach this is sort of to bifurcate
it between a discussion about longevity
and then we can get into the fasting
mimicking diet protocol that you talked
about but to kind of contextualise this
it would probably be good to hear a
little bit about your background and
what got you interested in aging and
longevity to begin with yeah so I
started actually very early I was music
major back in college so my second year
I think I always wanted to do aging do
research on Aging because as soon as I
had an opportunity to change I was
immediately sure I wanted to study Aging
and so I switched the biochemistry
department and it's all I've ever done
since then and there was 30 years ago
yeah that's something to do with having
to lead lead the band like the marching
band just crushed the rock star dream
yeah so they asked me to direct a
marching band and I say there's no way
I'm going to do that and they say well
you know this is the program if you
don't do that you gotta find something
else and so yeah within a couple days I
was in biochemistry and I think it was a
good switch and yes but what was the
impotent rest' in longevity come from is
that from growing up where you grew up
in Italy yeah you know I'm not sure I
speculate that maybe I was five years
old when I my father my grandfather died
but I was in the room when he died you
know you
you keep five-year-olds away from from
the actual moment where somebody dies
and it may be you know I acted very
grown-up at the time but maybe that's
that's stuck in my head that people die
and you know and and so there was very
early in my life that I had to face that
and yeah maybe I always wanted to look
for the opportunity to start studying
aging right now why how could I prevent
this from happening yes yes and no of
course then I started probably thinking
about me and my parents and and all of
that and and so yeah I suspect maybe
maybe had nothing to do with it but the
fact that I was so sure that I had to
study aging and I suspect it had more to
do than just a topic in college yeah
that's interesting because most people
might find themselves attracted to
science or biochemistry or becoming a
doctor but you were very specific and
what it is that you wanted to explore
yes specific and also I picked
biochemistry because at the time 19
years old I just taught biology in
chemistry that's probably gonna be good
to to know both to address the problem
of aging and but also I think that I
mean it's hard to to remember what I
thought at that time but certainly the
the potential for medicine to me was
also pretty obvious I just had spent a
few years in Chicago with my relatives
there I came from Italy but then in
Chicago I started seeing all these
cardiovascular disease and diabetes in
my relatives which are 100% genetically
from southern Italy mm-hmm and I never
saw that in in southern Italy I mean I
saw it but not like that
it was very obvious very early in the
50s and 60s and so that I think also was
a factor in my head and and so in Texas
the diet was also very poor you know
this tex-mex right so I guess it went
from bad to worse Chicago and Dallas and
then you know then eventually LA with
Roy Walford was one of the guru of
nutrition and longevity I had the
opportunity to go back to this
I deal at least I'd understanding of
what diet what which diet is good and
which is bad and he certainly was the
his lab was certainly the place to was
was your intention and going from it was
North Texas University as where you did
your undergrad coming out to UCLA were
you intentional about seeking out
Walford as a mentor like did you know
about him and that's what attracted you
to come to UCLA oh absolutely so there
were two people in in Los Angeles they
were essentially I think at least in my
view at the time and the view of many
Delta leading people in the world for
aging research la always had this for
some reason I'm not sure if it's
Hollywood or what it is everyone wants
to be permanently yes and so
interestingly the this scientist they
were attracted to LA we're also
attracted to be leaders in this field
and so Roy Walford was one and the other
one was Callie Finch at USC so I visited
both I applied to both programs and
eventually I chose to go to UCLA but and
you know a USC that's what I'm I still
am already four decades had a
comprehensive aging Center which is
unbelievable if you think about that
that this building called the Andrews
gerontology Center was built in the 70s
and the center was actually established
in the 60s hmm and yeah that's quite
traumatic because you know what people
probably don't know I mean there's so
much interest around what you do now but
there were many years where you struggle
to get your work published and just
people were not keen on on hearing what
you had to say so you know what was the
status of you know academia with respect
to aging research longevity research
then like what was Walford doing versus
like what's happening now yes so when I
talked about what for now everybody all
the journalists and everybody says oh
he's a hero and back then people make
fun of waffle he was like a you're like
a whack job he was it was viewed by his
own colleagues that you
la is out there I remember when I was in
the biochemistry department at the
comment when I said I'm gonna go to
pathology and work with Wofford and they
said we don't even know what they do out
there out there doing the experiments on
himself - that's always a red flag
yeah waffle was doing the experiment on
himself and and in fact that experiment
on himself my accustomed is life because
he he went for two years in this place
in Arizona called biosphere to him in
order seven people that's when I joined
his lab that's where he was he was
locked up in this sealed environment in
the middle of the desert and and many of
us suspect that you know and in in that
place he started the first human color
restriction experiment and himself and
disorder seven people and we suspect
that that might have cost him his life
he developed Lou Gehrig's disease and
which is a modern neuron disease and I
mean nobody knows for sure he may have
developed for some other reason but
there was some harsh conditions in that
in that by co2 between diet and oxygen
being law it is very possible those
those conditions led to his modern or
indeed yes like all pioneers they have
to test the outer limits right they got
a they got to push that envelope to see
what's possible absolutely and and well
for I think I didn't when he came out he
was in bad shape but and he he was
having doubts because at the time even
that operation was not really viewed as
is this a good idea was a stupid idea
and now I think most people view that
view as a you know pioneering operation
or event and and so I think if I think
by the time he died he was proud of what
he had done I'm not sure that it was
that sure when he came out in 92 so
before we kind of get into what you've
discovered through all of your research
into into this field
perhaps we should define our terms a
little bit like what what is agent
what causes it what exacerbates it and
what have you discovered can perhaps
slow it down yes so aging is actually
and I started the book by talking about
that aging is actually not a bad thing
right I mean violins age age and they
get better right and marathon runners
they get better
at least for a while as they age and
then you know maybe the peak performance
the from marathon runner Peaks around 32
to 35 which is very different from other
athletes senescence is really the word
that deals with changes that are
detrimental so accumulation of damage
and order this regulation that leads to
this function right so that's that there
were senescence usually we use aging
because people everybody understands
that word better so it's fine to use
aging but yeah so as time goes by
systems become accumulate damage and
they start becoming dysfunctional why
does the body suddenly become less than
less adept at repairing that damage well
I mean there are a lot of theories of
aging and a lot of people most people
have focused on the aging part itself I
come up with a term which I call
juvenility or you've ontology and the
difference is that I focus on what is
the program that keeps you young versus
or what is the process that makes you
all right so it's very different right
so imagine atala g vs juventus g is sort
of like the study and science of health
versus the study in science of disease
which is really the model the model of
Western medicine yes yes in a sense I
think so because if you studying things
going wrong aging right then you focus
on the deterioration so for example if
you think of a car and that's one of the
pillars that I talked about in the book
you can study the tires and you can say
okay I'm gonna learn everything about
the rubber how the rubber gets older and
older
and now to make it not get older
northern but I can come around with
ontology and say why you worry about
that just change the tires doing 50,000
miles and put a new set of tires and now
all of a sudden all their research you
can see how it's pointless right you
just have to find out right so you got
to figure out how the body can produce
new tires right which gets into this
stem cell regeneration
exactly you do super interesting put it
woody before we even get into that and
the next thing I want to talk about what
just occurred to me like what what do
you think of this trend amongst the new
kind of billionaire elite to like try to
live forever and you know the things
that Peter Thiel is looking into and
funding you know whether it's
cryotherapy type science or or other yes
I mean I don't know for sure but I've
been told that Walford was on the list
to be cryopreserved
Wow and and I was also told that
eventually he removed himself from the
list right so I think it's very
meaningful this this decision and I mean
I think all of us went through a period
of of thinking about immortality I think
you know when I was 20 I was probably
thinking the same way and then
eventually you start realizing that
that's probably not why we're here and
there is something fundamental you know
just impossible about it right you just
it's not consistent with life on earth
right and so and I'm not sure that and I
think that's probably what Walter
thought that woody want to wake up you
know in 20,000 years or 2,000 years and
find himself in the middle of God knows
what do you think about the implications
of your work as it sort of exponentially
develops that that could be a
possibility for human life yes but I
think you know first of all we really be
focusing even though you know we did
extend the lifespan of a yeast by
tenfold so certainly
we could move in that direction or much
more and continue and say well if we
were able with a microorganism to extend
the lifespan by tenfold couldn't we do
humans but we I decided a long time ago
that I didn't want to do that anymore
that I was much more interested in
getting everybody to be 110 healthy you
know like this Salvatore Caruso who's
from the same town as my grandfather was
this little town in southern Italy that
has record longevity they usually have
been between two and four centenarians
out of 2,000 peoples as one of the
highest in the world and Salvatore
Caruso made it 110 healthy and then I
also followed the EMA Murano in northern
Italy up to a few months ago Emma was
the oldest person in the world and the
oldest in the history of Italy and she
was under 17 and still eating on their
own and you know she wasn't completely
independent but mostly independent or
mostly
you know able to operate and do almost
everything within the house so I think
that that's really what we're what we're
studying now that's I think there would
be much greater achievement and then try
to make people live ten times longer
mm-hmm so your your research begins with
yeast cells it moves on to mice and then
ultimately to humans what is your
approach and what do you begin to learn
yeah so we Walford we were doing a lot
of comparative biology so you take a
mouse you starve and I mean you color
restrict and one that you don't want all
one young and then after a while I
thought I'm never gonna get anywhere
with this we just gonna have a lot of
differences but we don't know what they
mean we don't know what to do with it so
that's when I went to it back to the
genetics and me and maybe a group of 10
scientists in the unit mostly in the
United States a few in Europe they
decided let's go to fruit flies yeast
worms and they're so simple that we're
bound to figure out the age fairly
quickly identify genes that regulate
their aging quickly and then if we're
lucky we move back to
to mice and humans and and people
thought it was a joke right people
thought is this stupid I mean some
famous scientists in the field thought
it was a stupidest idea they've ever
heard you know that you could work in a
yeast unicellular organism and that
would somehow tell you our human age
right in fact a lot of people still
think it's a joke but that most people
think that though because it's a
fundamental question that we all would
like the answer to it's a fundamental
question but also you think about yeast
as some kind of ancient organism but
these organisms have evolved for as many
billions of years as we have right I
mean you know we are the results of the
same evolution process and and their
ancestors are our ancestors so they're
quite sophisticated and they obey the
same rules as human being I mean like
the force of natural selection so this
process that keeps an organism young for
a certain period of time
it's very is the same it acts in a
different way in a with a different
period and ie so in a yeast you just in
six days if in six days you basically
can reproduce enough time to get out of
the way and for us it's more like 50
years and but the rules are the same and
in fact it turned out that the genes
that we and others identified in these
simple organisms were the ones the same
ones that control aging in mice or very
very similar and we now have you know
from our own work evidence from genetic
mutations in humans suggesting that
right now the humans have certain
similar genes to the ones that we
identified in yeast deleted they they're
protected from aging right so what is
the structure that you set up to try to
determine what keeps the cell young or
what can sort of increase its longevity
yes so the the beginning it was used as
simple organism and use genetic tools
there at the time were only available
for yeast for baker's yeast right so for
example
one of our first studies that we publish
in science in the science journal was
let's delete every single gene in the
genome which is about 6,000 genes and
see which one is becomes most protected
against toxins right multiple toxins and
then the the hypothesis was is something
super protected against damage it's
gonna be protected against aging and
that worked out very well and that led
to the identification or was probably
now recognized as the most important Pro
aging path which the Tor assist kinase
pathway and and and so there was one
strategy use the tools genetic tools
that we had and the other one was
because I was in a well for lab and we
have some people lots of people working
on and and the molecular biology of
aging and the molecular biology of East
not aging nobody cared about aging at a
time but for example upstairs I had
somebody called Fujita monoi and he was
working on undress and we the field that
described our wrasse reacted or was
activated by sugar right so then I
started out of the wall for lab I said
sugar
activate wrasse and color restriction
extends the lifespan of all these
organisms they must be that if I delete
wrasse the East are going to live longer
so this is a biased approach versus what
I said earlier which is completely
unbiased and sure enough you know now
they live a lot longer they live two or
three times longer just by deleting with
this sugar gene so now the Tauruses
kinase is the protein pathway and the
peak raspy K is the sugar pathway right
you delete both of them you get tenfold
that's been extension Wow and then you
then step it up and and apply this to a
rat population yeah then then you apply
it to an inner cow case a mouse
population also knowing that the data
from from Cynthia Kenyon Gary African
and others in worms and flies right
which was matching so everything
starting to make sense there was all
aligned so tor was causing Aging in all
these organisms
activate it and if you did protein
restriction the organism live longer
right so just protein restriction so yes
so then you do the working in mice and
then of course you do the work with
nutrition and say well if having if
deleting the protein gene and the sugar
gene makes the organism live longer what
if I just remove sugar and proteins and
then you go in protein you say well do I
need to remove all proteins maybe not
maybe just certain amino acids that are
contained in protein so we remove serine
threonine and valine three amino acids
and show that those were the ones the
major ones in control the toward gene
right so yeah so then we started really
having a much more sophisticated
understanding of all the network the
controls aging in yeast and mice but
also understanding of the nutrients
within food they control the genes that
control aging right and then so then
with this population of mice these
studies that you were conducting how
much longer were they living so the the
mouse work was originally done by under
a barky and john captrick and these mice
remarkably lived up to twice as long
okay so it's pretty remarkable for
two-and-a-half year mouse to live five
years now right and but I don't the
equivalent in a human of how much longer
well this would be equivalent to humans
living an average of 165 years ago and
and so this was obtained by a
combination of mutation and nutrition so
restriction of protein restitution of
sugars and the mutation in the growth
hormone in this master gene the control
both Porto and PKA right right right and
and so then eventually we we knew about
the yeast tenfold longer the mouse twice
as long lived twice as long and then we
eventually start studying this
population in Ecuador that was lacking
the same gene the growth hormone
receptor that the mice made the mice
having this record longevity and and
sure enough you know they had a terrible
diet by the way
where did you figure out that they had
that same genealogy well there was a
endocrinologist Jaime Guevara down in
Ecuador they had been following them
because they were they have a small
stature phenotype they're small they're
about three and a half feet tall and and
so he was studying them because of that
right the karate was trying to get him
to be taller right and so it was falling
a hundred of em and and to me was just
an incredible opportunity so I remember
when when Hussey Kohana you see a light
on me you get a call this Jaime evaru
because he's following a hundred of this
subject and needy noses each one of them
by name so I immediately invited him at
USC to give a talk and then I went down
there and then eventually it took us
five years and he always complains that
it took us too long but it took us five
years to publish the first paper in
Science Translational Medicine showing
protection from diabetes and cancer and
his formulation but they were eating a
terrible diet and then he went down and
like what was the protocol at you that
you applied to that population yeah we
didn't apply any protocol the the the
task was to in a way without affecting
anything that they do randomized them in
a sense right so having relatives
against them right they live in the same
houses eat the same food what are the
relatives dying off and a what age and
what are the this group they are it's
called gh Rd growth hormone receptor
deficient what do they die off in a wall
age and so it looked like at least in
2011 there wasn't a single cancer that
that we could find either in these
hundred subjects in in in the ecuador
nor in the 250 subjects that has villa
Ronn had been following Europe and the
Middle East so I loved 350 people in 50
years of observation not a single cancer
that now that happened later probably
due to this terrible diet you know a
certain point these genes are not right
able to create immunity against cancer
but in thus far there's been three cases
of diabetes again out of the 350 or so
subjects which is another extremely low
prevalence of diabetes considering that
they have a terrible diet a lot of em
are obese and overweight so yeah so then
then this mutation in humans seems to be
very much behaving like the the mouse
mutation which makes them protector from
diabetes protected from cancer the mice
and also a very long live now the
longevity we don't see a big effect on
longevity there's probably a small
effect on longevity but we suspect as we
know for mice that by having a terrible
diet this may be not removing the
protection against diseases but removing
this record on diabetes right right
right
so you deduce from that what and how
does that inform like the next chapter
well from that we we deduced that it
works right it's not a mouse or a yeast
finding these this is this is going
after cellular protection or
multi-system cellular protection across
the board so so then these mice that
could get to 50% longer life by have
health of the cancers and protection of
diabetes from pressure for inflammation
protection from cognitive decline their
brain work better and longer and we also
showed that for the humans so now all of
this is possible you just started to say
well we don't have to be this you know
Western world of living long very sick
now you know you used to live a little
bit shorter or healthier now we live
longer sicker and we can live longer
healthier so the opposite of what we
obtained in now so now we're keeping
people alive with lots of drugs lots of
intervention yeah the idea that
extending longevity will only extend the
period of time in which you're sick is
the paradigm you're trying to upend yeah
we want to turn it completely around so
not only we don't go to a higher because
of course as soon as you start saying we
want to make people live 20 years longer
then they say 30 years longer than now
right people are gonna say no absolutely
not because they think of all the people
that they know right you're just all
sick old folks home the whole time you
know unable to walk yeah so but if you
look at mi Murano ooh
112 could still live in in our house
alone right I mean she didn't live alone
but she could have if she wanted to meet
she had people that came but I think
into 100 506 she was alone leaving a lot
and yeah and also if you saw some other
Caruso 110 you think that's pretty good
right yeah I won't that mean Salvatore
area you know in the in the latest years
that you know television used to come
National Geographic came and they did a
cover story on him and not just him but
uh centenarians and he loved it you know
he was so happy that getting so much
attention is getting attention but he
was healthy you know yeah you could come
out and and walk and walk with the
television crews and so yeah he was
healthy enough to really enjoy all this
attention so Dan Buettner is a friend of
mine he's been in here a couple times so
we've talked extensively on the podcast
about the work that he's done on the
Blue Zones and and your work really
intersects with his work you know in a
very beautiful way you're looking at the
same or similar populations of people
evaluating what is contributing to their
health and their longevity and you know
when you talk to Dan it's a it's a it's
calm it's confounding factors it's its
diet it's lifestyle it's community it's
making the Healthy Choice the convenient
the easy choice it's you know continual
sort of movement throughout the day but
nothing too crazy nobody's on treadmills
or going to the gym they're just active
throughout their day they're engaged
with their relatives and you know
they're they're sort of neighbors in a
way that we're not the way that we live
here a lot of these communities you know
have a strong faith component to them so
you kind of surveying all of this and
thinking about what you're doing in the
lab where do you start to look at
alright well I can I can sort of
deconstruct all of these factors
but it's really the nutrition piece that
you zero in on and you can kind of
extrapolate from the essentially
Mediterranean diet that most of these
people are eating very low protein not
very much meat lots of legumes and nuts
and seeds and vegetables and the like
what does that like where does that
where does Dan's work intersect with
yours and like where do you then kind of
take it further yes so then it's a
friend of mine now so I think he's done
great work and and we see the Blue Zones
and other areas of the world that are
they have record longevity as one of the
major pillars so in the book I talk
about five pillars and that's one of
them right so the centenares are one but
there are all four pillars and and and
why is this important for example one of
the other pillars is epidemiology why is
it important well epidemiology is really
looking at large population and saying
okay what if you had low protein versus
high protein low fat versus life at who
does better right so a few years ago we
published a paper they got a lot of
attention where we said we'll win
against the idea of high protein diet
but we win against it and we went for it
at the same time right and this is where
the sophistication of the multi pillar
strategy comes in
meaning that up to age 65 the low
protein in plant-based diet seemed to be
ideal after age 65 that was not the case
anymore
and so people protein needs become more
important yeah and we also show why
because we had mouse and human data in
the same paper and if you took a mouse a
young mouse and you give a stream in low
protein take four percent of the
calories coming from protein the young
mice did perfectly well then you took
all mice and you give four percent
protein and they started dropping weight
very rapidly right that's where the the
science and this is just one of the four
or four extra pillars of science that we
use this is why it's so important now if
you look at sent an e you know for
example Colin Campbell it's always
talked about low protein diet right but
he's always talked about two problems
you know and I really think it's been a
pioneer in the low protein but you
cannot have and this also happened with
the colorization field
them back you give something that is
good and it's bad at the same time if
the end and neutralizes can neutral
effect so what's the problem with saying
it low-protein go with the only
population studies the problem is that
you don't see for example that you can
make somebody so weak that their immune
system shuts off when they're 82 because
they thought the proteins always bad
another thing that is not bad for
example and there is different phases of
life is weight if you are overweight
when you're 50 is clearly bad right or
obese if you're overweight when you're
82 it's actually protective right so a
slightly now obese but certainly in the
25 26 BMI that's actually a good thing
right
so low protein hype moderate protein or
low pro down to a 65 moderate protein
vegan let's say up to age 65 or
pescetarian fish plus vegan plus
vegetable up to age 65 and they maybe
expand a little bit these are all tricks
that come from really putting all these
pillars together you may not see by just
going to Italy for example Italy very
few people in Italy am assuming Greece
are very frail populations when they're
alright very few people know this so
these Italians they live so long in
Sardinia and Calabria and other areas
are actually very free off later than
the people in Northern Europe right and
that comes probably from this continuing
this low protein diet and continuing
this
narrower diet that is so helpful when
you're younger and now it becomes
detrimental it makes you weak when
you're all the right so it gets yeah I
got you I got you yeah I mean basically
like like everything it's more nuanced
and complicated than we want to believe
you know we want to reduce it down to
one core principle that's applicable to
everybody no matter what age or how they
where they find themselves in life is
there a difference between so on this on
this idea that when you hit 65 and as
you start to you know move in that
direction
where your protein needs become more
important has there been any work done
on the differences between animal
protein
and plant protein I mean you certainly
don't want to be taking in a lot of
igf-1 when you're older right you're
gonna be more susceptible to cancer not
necessarily because now and that's what
shown in the paper the igf-1 is so low
because of age that eating high protein
or Lowepro that made no difference in a
gf1 so the people they had over 20
percent of the calories from protein and
the people that had learned less than 10
percent at the same levels of igf-1 so
so yeah so I think that it gets much
trickier than then we won't appreciate
another issue for example that I under
discuss in my book but I think it should
be much more discussed is outer
immunities and immunities and allergies
right so you can have a vegetable based
diet but then whether it's gluten or
it's like tins or it is some
pro-inflammatory vegetables to a
percentage which could be a significant
percentage if you think about how to
immunities are increasing at a rate of
17% in the world every year right it's a
huge increase so this is exposure to a
lot of this potentially or apparently
healthy foods to some people and it
could be quite a big number can be
detrimental right so this is why in the
book I stopped talking about gluten and
talking about lactose but I said really
gotta pay attention because you may
think something is super healthy for you
and that something may be killing you so
you you you need to find out are you out
to immune allergic intolerant to
something and and that's something maybe
20 different foods which are all
vegetable by the way right so so if you
don't remove it you're gonna have a
problem and you're gonna suffer in a
clear case I always talk about Italy and
in the lactose years I used to go to
Italy and I said this is really
incredible and because 90% of the
Sicilians are lactose intolerant uh-huh
and yet for until 5 years ago I never
seen a coffee shop in Sicily that serves
a soy milk or almond milk they had the
regular milk so I said you know
everybody that is drinking this must be
suffering and so you have a whole you
had the whole country they was getting
the macchiato the last Asia and
all cow milk and they must this is must
contributed to an epidemic of
gastrointestinal disorders they were
very obviously some people we knew that
they were lactose intolerant and yet
nobody nothing was done funny alright so
on this idea of the five pillars you
know let's talk about what we can
extract from the research that you've
done and what you've learned you know
into some principles that can kind of
guide us in the direction of promoting
longevity in our own lives like what's
most important I'm asking you to be
reductionist after my my my speech about
how we shouldn't be reductionist yeah
yeah so I mean so you're asking about
the most important well yeah I just want
to kind of move into this area of you
know what people should be aware of and
some habits and some practices that they
can adopt and also things to avoid so
that people can be more mindful of you
know how to practice you know these
principles that you speak about for
their own well yes yes so then number
one I think is a pescetarian diet why is
that well if you are vegan lots of times
you hear people saying oh I thirty grams
or garbanzo beans or chickpeas there
should be enough proteins it's not right
you need about ten times as much as that
I've been vegan for eleven years
no I'm not sure you can be vegan and do
very well but most people out there are
not you that's right that's my point
right but he always tells me I'm an
outlier I'm not convinced about that
voltar don't know and now I'm saying
vegan is perfectly fine I'm just saying
that being vegan and healthy is much
harder than people think
right because for example it takes about
four hundred great grams of chickpeas to
have enough proteins right and not a lot
of times forget you let's say we pick
ten vegans out there right at random we
pick the first time we can find and we
start asking question I do this all the
time and you'd be surprised how many
times you say what you haven't had b12
in a while and and you have another
proteins in three or four days and a you
no problem at surprising the price so
I'm just saying if you're going
be vegan great but you gotta pay
attention yeah I don't know I I mean I I
think look I take a b12 supplement like
I don't know once a week at most I have
my blood work done it's fine I go out
and I do these crazy ultra endurance
races I'm able to compete on 51 I feel
good I've never had any problems
building lean muscle mass or recovering
in between workouts so I think there's a
lot of misconception out there about
protein and I think one thing we can
agree on is that most people are eating
too much protein there's plenty of plant
foods that meet my amino acid needs I'm
not eating buckets full of garbanzo
beans but you know it mindful about it I
think I would concede to you that that
it's easier and easier to eat a very
nutrient poor vegan diet especially with
all the analog products that are coming
out and people moving further and
further away from you know sort of
nutrient-dense whole whole plant foods
yeah I mean you know we're in the under
Swain same choir right so so absolutely
I you know I published on that and I got
attacked for talking about low protein
diet mostly vegan but then again the
when you allow people to have a so fish
in the diet to the big population it
makes it much much less likely that
they're gonna lose a lot of lean body
mass that they're gonna struggle and
also makes it less likely that they're
gonna switch back right so if you say
I'm gonna allow you to have fish plus a
vegan diet a lot so people are fine with
that if you remove everything then then
then it's just harder for people now if
somebody can be vegan for ethical reason
or whatever great I mean I think it's
absolutely doable there are no no reason
not to be vegan it just says that you
have to pay attention I think that we
would also agree that that that this
protein obsession that we find ourselves
in the midst of is is really a red
herring I mean most people people are
walking around worried about their
protein intake where when in truth
they're probably taking in two to five
times more protein than they need and
what every product at the grocery store
you know is emblazoned with a message
about how much protein it is you know
with the implication like oh we must be
not getting enough or we need more and
what I like about your work is you you
stand in you know contra position to
that idea yeah absolutely and and I'm
the first one they will say we're gonna
have an epidemic of over protein or
eating too much protein and we're gonna
find out the consequence is very soon I
mean in our paper we show three to four
for the increase in cancer incidence
right and seventy five percent increase
in overall mortality in the following 20
years for people that were 65 and below
and even for the 65 and above it was the
moderate protein intake it was not the
high didn't need to have high protein
intake moderate was sufficient the
meaning that in fact in my book I talk
about maybe increased the protein intake
by 20 percent when you get to age 65 70
below the minimum recommended right so
yeah absolutely
but then again if you look at fish and I
have to go with the science and if you
look at more studies fish is always on
the positive side beside the mercury
fish you know there's four fish and the
tuna XL problem you know but most
studies are showing beneficial effects
right that's why I have to say even
though some people could argue well
Attica Lee you know may or may not be
the best idea but if you look at the
science the fish plus vegan seems to but
it would be the way to go and what is it
I think when you you haven't sort of
said it explicitly but this relationship
between meat intake and the incidence of
cancer like what is going on there cuz I
think when you say that to somebody like
basically saying meat causes cancer is
that what you're saying and if it's not
if it is if it isn't like I want to kind
of clarify that yeah I mean I don't say
that now the World Health Organization
says that so does every other major
Association I think the National Cancer
Institute you no doubt this is USDA I
think is also now reduced recommendation
and protein because of that so red meat
particularly is now recognized by almost
every major
Association specialize in cancer to be a
risk factor or certainly something that
you want to avoid in it I quantities in
our case you know we had multiple papers
we and and Harvard School of Public
Health there published a series of
papers all of them come in agreement
with this idea particularly for red meat
but just also for prod high-protein so
after our paper we publish one with a
java neutral Harvard and also confirming
the de plant-based diet was protective
compared to a variety of diets and
included a high protein from from animal
sources and what is the the active
component in meat or red meat that's
causing these problems is that the high
density of protein is it the the
hormonal breakdown in it like what can
that be drill down to nobody knows for
sure I mean there's a lot of
speculations that some of it having to
do with him content and I've heard
different stories and and different
hypotheses it could be are they fed
steroid hormones are they fed
antibiotics Uno's right what what is in
that meat and so probably the
combination of high proteins but also
other molecules that make it into the
meat out there are probably contributing
to to make it very clear that
particularly the red meat seems to be
detrimental but in our paper we showed
that all the animal high protein diet
from from all animal sources were the
tremendo and in high plant-based diet
was no longer detrimental high protein
from plant-based sources was no longer
detrimental for overall mortality so
there's no effect but it still was was
detrimental for cancer so he still
showed up if somebody had lots of
proteins from from vegetable sources
that still was associated with an
increased risk for cancer but that was
was in most cases a combination of
animal and and plant-based right I got
you what about what about saturated fat
yeah so I think one of the point that I
make in the in the book is that this
demonization of ingredients or
macromolecules has been very
micronutrients as being very bad so we
should start making distinctions between
types of micronutrients or fats are
actually very good for you number of
studies now looking at the nuts and
looking at the olive oil and looking at
Salman etc they're all positive but when
you look at you know the high saturated
fats diet then you see you see problems
now what will happen if you have a low
sugar low protein high saturated fat
diet nobody knows is it possible that
that would be okay possible I wouldn't
go in that direction because we don't
have the studies yet and it's
potentially I mean if you want to kill a
mouse earlier you give them a hive
saturated fat diet right right and so
yeah I think there's there's there's a
lot of confusion out there right now I
mean on the one hand you have people
like Colin Campbell even you know Joel
Khan and the others who are you know
cautioning people against their
saturated fat intake and you know
indicating that the studies seem to
point to a higher incidence of
cardiovascular disease with the intake
of these things and then on the other
side of the fence you have a whole group
of people and it's some emerging
excitement about this notion that
everything you ever heard about
saturated fat is wrong that you should
be putting butter in your coffee and you
should be in ketosis and pricking your
finger and you know like taking
exogenous ketones
so where do you come down on the
ketogenic diet where do you come down on
on this this kind of dissension amongst
health professionals of
this subject yeah I call it the 0.5
pillar strategies right so you come up
with a cup of studies showing acute
effects let's say you eat a lot lots of
butter and after 3 months you can look
at a bunch of 20 people and they show
like lower cholesterol and this zero
point five pillars approach is very
dangerous right and why is it very
dangerous now for example if you take
mice and you give it a low high protein
diet right and and relatively high fat
they actually lose weight and you know
if you stop the study right there you
say this is a good diet you know if you
continue eventually they develop
metabolic diseases and they die early
but if you give them a low protein diet
high carbohydrate diet they actually
gain a little weight
if you stop there you will say a bad bad
idea if you continue they have less
metabolic diseases and they live a lot
longer so why is a problematic then to
have zero point five health a pillar
well because you're gonna get surprised
and and so if you look at Oh many many
many studies many of which I list in my
book you see that the the law of fat
avoiding the saturated fats over and
over and over is a good idea avoiding
the unsaturated the olive oil nuts etc
it's a bad idea so for example the the a
stroke study in Spain
thousands of people randomised trial you
put health of them and lots of olive oil
or lots of nuts every day they had to
stop the study because it was unethical
for the control group not to have the
same right but if you look at as hosting
work and you look at the dean ornish and
not just them but lots lots of data you
see that you know having high saturated
fat diet is associated with a lot of
cardiovascular problems now if you look
go around the world you look at the
centenarian piller none of them have
high saturated fat Nadia Okinawa's nada
Loma Linda not this old Indians that the
Calabrian not the Costa Ricans and not
the people in in Greece in in Korea so
yeah so then you have to say the animal
data doesn't support it epidemiological
data doesn't support the centenarian
data doesn't support it you know the
basis the basic research doesn't support
there is really in the in the clinical
randomized clinical study doesn't
support it so you have to say well in 30
years when you have you know 200 more
studies all supporting this which will
be almost impossible because there's
already so much negative data annum
mm-hmm so now worth it now were to go in
that direction you can do as well by
being on a low sugar low starch high
carbohydrate diet it is there anything
people they like to say bad cop good car
right it's not about again same as fat
it's about sugars and starches pasta
bread it's not about carbs carbs
contained in legumes
and the Cubs contains in vegetables are
excellent carbs and even the ones for
starches if you have if you maintain a
relatively low it's fine you know it
makes your your diet more enjoyable and
so if you have 50 grams of pasta or rice
that's perfectly fine if you have a
hundred and twenty grams so that then
you starting to get into the problem so
right so so I think that that this we
really must start applying this five
pillar or not five pillar people can
have seven pillars you know whatever
they want but certainly
multidisciplinary approaches to
determine whether a high butter diet is
good or not versus somebody's opinion
based on 20 people studying right I
understand where you're coming from I
mean the the the you know the starch
thing makes a lot of sense may not
echoes the work of John McDougall if you
talk to Esselstyn though he's gonna take
a very hard line on fats and oils
altogether like he's advocating for an
extremely low fat diet no oils granted
he's dealing with cardiovascular
patients that for the most part are in
you know dire need of having to reverse
some pretty progressed arterial damage
it's a little bit different but he takes
a very hard line on that like what is
your perspective the book you know and
so I say well that line though is one
pillar line right so the line to go with
the law such ready fat is a five pillar
line the line to go with no fats of any
kind is a one pillar line nobody nothing
else supports that so if you look at at
the Sardinians they always had lots of
olive oil so there are the Greeks and I
think also the the people in Costa Rica
and the Loma Linda people so none of
them and then if you look at the
clinical data the other pillar the a
stroke study are showing that they had
to stop the study against a low-fat diet
so the randomization was olive oil and
nuts versus low fat tie so three
thousand people also went on a low-fat
diet and what was the low-fat diet
we just suggested to eat less fat right
so now the high fat from olive oil and
nut diet was so superior to the low fat
diet that they had to stop the study so
yeah then that's when you have to say
any and if you give a high fat diet and
now they're I'm not sure if they also
had saturated fats in there but I said
certainly you know the mouse studies are
I think they haven't really been done I
say good fats bad fats low carb low
protein all right but just to be like
totally kick clear and like drill down
on this nutrition piece essentially what
you're advocating is a plant-based whole
food diet with some fish in terms of
like the best protocol for long-term
lifestyle management and longevity
it's that fair yes avoiding the paying
attention to autoimmunity Xin tolerances
and so yeah making sure you're not
allergic to certain things yeah and
essentially and then you know once you
get to 65 then I I think that things
change and they'll say god you're good
maybe some goat cheese and and some of
these ingredients that may be high
nourishment eggs for example
may be a good idea to start introducing
them back just because you know of what
we see this we've seen his frailty in
later life that you know if your diet is
too restrictive
you're probably gonna suffer from from
this malnourishment
so as I've mentioned I've been you know
playerbase for 11 years and and when I
began this journey I promised to myself
that I would be objective and
transparent about my experience with it
that if I started to not feel good or if
my blood work was reflective of
something gone awry that I would be
honest about that and make adjustments
that hasn't happened yet but you know 65
no I'm 51 I know I'm not there yet but I
feel great
so perhaps because there's a lot of
plant-based vegan people that listen to
this who are thinking wait now I got to
start eating that like what should I be
mindful about if I want to remain on
this plant-based path yeah well mindful
of for example that 30 grams of
chickpeas and a salad gives you about 3
to 5 grams of products right and even if
you take the lowest level of protein
that you can consider you know the World
Health Organization in their studies to
maintain normal nitrogen balance they
talked about 0.66 per kilogram right so
about 0.32 grams of protein per pound of
body weight per day right this is
official based on studies right so if
you go much lower than that you're gonna
start losing muscle mass it's just a
matter of time so now of course if you
if you say eh well how much carbon
Sabine's did I have today let's say
you're a hundred and twenty pound women
and there is vegan you know you're gonna
need about 40 grams of protein 35 40
grams of protein minimum right now in
the book I said I talked about the fact
that you know if you have 35 40 grams of
plant-based protein and you do some
weight training there should be plenty
there should be planning to to keep a
good muscle mass but you have to do it
every day right this is something that
the
something that you have to continue
doing otherwise you might not see it but
year after year of the year you can
start losing lean body mass and then you
know and but the problem is also are you
gonna start losing sa immune function
again it's an age dependent of fact so
you might not see until you see 62 63 64
you might see it in 55 you know you may
be there it may be that you get cancer
when you're 55 and that was due to the
fact that your immune system is not
working as well as the cool hat because
your protein deficient or you b12
deficient or your vitamin D deficient or
your folic acid efficient so it's very
important to to say let me avoid the
malnourishment without interfering or
with the with beneficial effects so yeah
without needing to go into an area that
where the the protein becomes detriment
mm-hmm yeah my protein needs on that
equation of you know 0.32 comes out to
about between 60 and 70 grams a day it's
just it's not that hard like I some
almond butter I you know rice and beans
I eat lentils and quinoa and things like
that as long as I'm just eating those
foods like I've done the math and it
seems to it it almost takes care of
itself
like if I'm just eating clean
plant-based foods close to the retro
state so it's not about going out of my
way to make sure I'm eating you know
tons of carbons of beans or anything no
no no I mean I do that fight that fight
is a weak mind so my diet is plant-based
fight this week there's no problem but I
do pay attention I know yeah then a
certain amount of certain vegetable
contains so much product or so and so
once you get used to that you know to
check anything so it's very
straightforward I'm just saying that I
suspect when they compare I say the
vegans against the non vegans and they
show that the vegans are not doing
better in those studies I suspect that's
because so many people in the vegan
group are malnourished and that's why
you see this otherwise III think the
vegans should've been doing much much
better than the non vegans if it wasn't
for my nourishment so if we could turn
the vegans into well nourished vegan
then I think we'll see the superiority
that we already see in the blue zones
and in
Malinda etc yeah I think that's astute I
mean I think my fear and I think it's a
very real fear is that as we continue to
produce all of these processed versions
of meat and dairy products that are
tasting better and better and better
that people that are entering into you
know becoming vegan can easily just be
eating all sorts of refined grains all
the time and cookies and snacks and
things like that and they're you know
they're like hey I'm vegan it's healthy
when in fact it perhaps might even be
worse than whatever they were doing
before yes absolutely so I think that
this is why I talk about you know once
you figure out what the science and all
these pillars are saying go back to your
grandparents table and among the healthy
things pick the ones that were coming at
their table you know and so if you do
that then I think you're guaranteed
especially if you go with the
grandparents or great-grandparents that
you're gonna eliminate a lot of these
these new processed foods that you're
talking about so I mean I don't think
there are many - too many grandparents
that ate you know processed food you
know in the past so right there's been
much much ado lately about the
relationship between chronic
inflammation and the onset of so many of
these lifestyle illnesses that we're
seeing I'm interested in your
perspective on that and what the
relationship is between inflammation and
aging yes that's a little tricky I think
it's clearly there there is no doubt
there in the brain and and lots of
people in the Western countries or have
high inflammation inflammatory markers
to me is more of a consequence of
dysfunction than the cause of
dysfunction so I think that the body the
liver is not working well and so you
start making c-reactive protein as a as
a way to respond to a dysfunctional
state and this is why we developed the
fasting mimicking diet and the idea was
to
you know we can't change everybody's
habits but can we for example go after
the inflammation not just during the
diet but in the couple of month two or
three months after the diet so is it
possible to hit some somebody with a
five-day diet they will have long term
consequences and the inflammatory State
but not just the inflammatory state but
certainly that is one way to I think
assess functionality of the entire
system right okay so let's let's get
into this world of fast I mean when does
it first become evident to you that this
relationship between Cal caloric
restriction and the impact you know
biochemically positive impacts
biochemically starts to percolate into
your awareness and and where do you go
with that yes so first of all a caloric
restriction which is what Walford was
doing which refers to eating as a 25% to
30% less all the time it doesn't work
right it doesn't work for some reason we
know some reason we don't know but even
in mice you know the original
observation were made 100 years ago and
then it turns out that about 1/3 of the
genetic backgrounds benefited from
calorie restriction a third were had
neutral effects and a third had negative
effects but so I think the periodic
fasting mimicking died build on this
success and failure why it's a success
affair success because if you look at
colors to the people or monkeys it's
obvious that the positive effects are
remarkable for example in the monkeys
they were calorie restricted the the
control monkey 60% of them developed
diabetes in the colours of the monkey
zero in the cardiovascular disease and
cancer reduction by 50% phi0 which is in
what kind of caloric restriction this
was just 25 percent monkeys right now if
you look at the lifespan not change very
much right so then what does it tell you
it tells you that obviously you could
probably cure many many diseases by
doing the right intervention but color
restriction is not the way to do it
because it gives you as many problems as
Solutions this is the Inhumans and any
any monkeys humans we don't know for
sure yet but if you look at people that
are cut restricted you know man the
records they should have BMI of nineteen
eighteen point five nineteen they look
like the really borderline anorexic and
you know and you have to wonder is this
sustainable - is it compatible with a
lifespan of 110 probably not as it
wasn't for the monkeys so that's where
then you know back in the days I made
the observation if I completely starve
bacteria or I completely starved yeast
they live longer and they live stronger
right so longer stronger meaning that
you you hit them with toxins nothing
they're very strong and and both of them
and you know if you look at bacteria and
yeast bees that you carry it so they're
being separated by hundreds of millions
of years so I started thinking is it
possible that you could do this for
every organism and it's gonna make a
stronger and protected for a long period
and that's where a lot of this comes
from and so jumping I had twenty years
then is the mouse studies that we first
did which were you know what if you take
a mouse and you give it this fast in
making that why is it a fast American
diet is a you know what I was talking
earlier about the nutrient determine
what genes are activated or not sighs so
if you have a certain composition low
protein low levels of certain amino
acids and then I have lost sugar high
carbohydrate but lost sugar and high fat
but good fats right all that you put it
together then the response of the system
is just like if you giving it water only
fasting you just give water and you heal
for for four days and then you put them
back on a bad diet a relatively bad diet
this is a vegan so for vegan days for
the mice and then you know ten days of
animal-based diet and then you keep
doing this twice a month now we show the
the mice live longer about 11 percent
longer but the remarkable part is the
cancers were reduced by almost 50% Wow
and in the inflammatory diseases were
reduced by 50% and this mice just their
cognitive abilities was was much
improved right
they just look younger healthier so they
live longer younger and healthier then
we did the human clinical trial with
this proton fast imaging diet and we did
three cycles once a month five days
again vegan five vegan days of this low
protein Lord Sugar
hide good fat diet and and then we give
them 25 days of no recommendation go
back and do whatever it is that you
always done no exercise recommendation
or food no nutrition recommendation and
then we measure the effects after a week
and three months after the last cycle
and you know I think the results were
remarkable saw a lower cholesterol blood
pressure lower triglyceride lower
fasting glucose lower inflammation
systemic inflammation is measured by CRP
and lower igf-1 which we believe is that
one of the key markers risk factors were
both aging in cancer but the interesting
thing this happened much more power it
was much more powerful in people that
had the problem to begin with so if
somebody started from an ideal situation
there were a lot less changes then
somebody that started with high levels
of this yeah of course of course
that's absolutely fascinating was there
any were you able to sort of quantify
when you said okay go back and eat
whatever you were eating were you aware
of you know the differences in how
people were returning to their
lifestyles and was there any
differentiation amongst that population
based upon their just sort of preset
lifestyle I mean we knew that again the
the people that for example had igf-1
levels of 300 they probably had a very
high animal protein that is right and
they responded very very very well we
didn't follow their diet
after but what we heard from lots of
people and now you know the proton FMD
has been done by over 30,000 people so
we're starting to collect a lot of data
from from people and a lot of people are
basically saying it's a slow process but
every
time I do a cycle I come back and I
don't feel like I have to go back to as
much meat I don't have to go back to as
much sugar or as many coffees well
they've done something for themselves
and so then they you know they're more
enthusiastic about taking care of
themselves I would imagine I think so I
may also be something about you know the
brain realizing it that you can handle I
always think about I say running a 10k
run the first time you do it you you
it's very difficult yeah and after that
you could probably do it multiple times
a year and it doesn't seem that hard I
think is you know realizing that it's
okay it's not that hard most people
haven't have never gone and you know 24
hours in their entire life without
eating solid food and just the idea of
that seems so daunting we you know we
have this notion that we'll just perish
if we do that and to kind of undertake a
protocol like that and go to the other
side of it and realize like oh that was
I did that that was fine makes you
rethink the human body's capabilities
yeah absolutely and if you think about
for example the brain around a five or
so or the FMD about fifty percent of the
fuel comes from ketone bodies right from
fat and and in most people that pathway
in the brain has probably never been
activated right so somebody could be 55
years of age and never once has
activated this use of ketone bodies in
the brain mmm so then what's wrong with
with exploring the ketogenic diet all
the time the pillars so you know II if
you look around the world a population
that are long-lived using a ketogenic
diet all the time which in most cases to
be doable that to be a high-protein diet
you know I mean you could come up with
it but it'd be almost impossible to do
like a high-fat only you know low-carb
it'd be almost impossible so this will
end up being a high protein high fat
diet and there is really no data out
there and so then you're taking a big
risk right so I got you all right so the
genesis of this is this idea that when
you fast a cell something gets triggered
in that cell to make it protective and
stronger against disease and decline
that correct so what is going on
cellularly
yeah so that's one that was the initial
observation protection then we started
realizing it wasn't just about
protection as I was talking about the
tires earlier it's about also repair and
replacement right both inside of a cell
whether the cell if the cell doesn't die
and in inside of an organ where the
cells are actually killed and replaced
right so now the body and I I used the
analogy with a wood burning train and I
say imagine you have a wood burning
train is running out of fuel it cannot
make it to the next train station so it
starts burning its own components to get
there right but of course the the
engineer there is burning the wood will
first call to the ruined chairs that are
made of wood in the room world you know
the damaged ones right so you take the
damaged component and burn those right
that would make sense first then you go
to everything else but the end result is
you get to the next station and then you
rebuild and now you put new chairs new
walls inside now you have a newer train
and you made it there and that's exactly
what the body does you get rid of a lot
of junk inside of the cell and also
inside of an organ and it seemed like we
publish a people for example a few years
ago on multiple sclerosis there Mouse
and humans and it seemed like the this
fasting mimicking diet was able to first
get rid of auto immune cells and it
makes sense right it's like like the
machinist or the engineer and the train
you go picked damage one way I mean it
would be surprising that after billions
of years of Oulu evolution the body was
dumb enough to go pick first the good
cells and kill them when it knows that
some cancer some cells are precancerous
some cells are autoimmune some cells are
not metabolically you know it may be
insulin resistant and that's why we
think
we see in the human trial this
rejuvenation effect the body seems to be
working like when people were much
younger so yes so essentially you know
on first glimpse it's sort of like oh
the body is cannibalizing itself that
can't be good but in truth what's
happening is it's purging itself of
these cells that are in decline and in
so doing stimulating stem cell
regeneration for these organs and these
systems to rebuild themselves with brand
new healthy cells yeah
not just stem cells now we are now our
new work is looking at inside of the
cell right so you like a neuron or a
cardio myocyte
may not be may not be killed but it's
now gonna regenerate into salary right
so is this me out of goog apoptosis no
this is the killing of the cell that
we've already shown what we're now
looking at is what happens inside of the
cell without killing the cell can you
regenerate the intracellular components
I see I see
and so in other words like take the
liver for example I think you know I've
read and seen were you've spoken about
how you undergo this protocol and your
organs your liver will literally shrink
right because it's because it's
regenerating itself and getting rid of
the old and in the early processes of
building the new and then you go back to
your life where you're eating and it
regenerates itself and it's actually for
all intents and purposes it's a younger
organ is that correct yes so I mean
obviously for example we're showing that
the white blood cell number the clients
and then and then returns to normal
right so it's not like the clients with
20% right so you're not reducing
something by 80% you might be reducing
about 15%
but now 15% of the white blood but let's
say even 10% so 10% and then you rebuild
it now if we do this 10 times a year and
especially speculating that what we seen
in mice is also true for humans meaning
that the body can
this is a damaged cell there's nothing
right of 10% which might represent 70%
of the bad cells right I mean I don't
know we've never demonstrated that but
certainly we demonstrated that we could
take out two immune mice and and within
so many cycles of the FASTA mimicking
diet we can eliminate completely the
autoimmunity in 20% of these mice and we
can reduce it dramatically in 50% of
device right so I mean it's working you
know in a memo very well and we've shown
it with the pancreas we can destroy the
pancreas make it not generating insulin
anymore and then we start with the cycle
of the fasting minion diet these
embryonic genes are turned on and the
only time you see this gene turn on in
this manner is only when we when the
mouse is first born right and so they've
turned on and they start rebuilding the
pancreas you know and the insulin
producing sauce it's really remarkable
process now you know in humans we're
starting the trial so we you know
there's a lot of work to be done and
people have to be careful not to think
about oh okay now I'm gonna I have
diabetes like one I'm gonna go do it
it's you know it's still dangerous to do
it but looks very promising and now
we're gonna start clinical trials and
Crohn's and Colitis Alzheimer diabetes
cancer of course we'd be doing trials
for years now we're done with a few of
them and we're doing more you know
multiple sclerosis etc what do you think
is the the number one study like what
would be the first study that needs to
be conducted to answer some of the
lingering questions that you have that
you would like answers to well the first
one we're gonna do where I think it's
gonna work as they already work with a
hundred patient clinical trial that we
did is metabolic syndrome and
pre-diabetes and pre cardiovascular
state right so all the people which is
half of the you knows people American
yeah but a third of Americans are either
pre-diabetic or diabetic about 100
million people so yeah so we think
because we already done it and we saw
very clear results now we're gonna do
that we're gonna start very soon about
400 patients randomized at USC and yeah
so that I have high hopes that that's
the way to go you know maybe three times
a year
do this you know in the trial we're
gonna do three cycles monthly but we
envisioned because in the past trial we
saw that three months after the last the
third cycle we still still so about 60%
of the changes remaining Wow so they
incur 60% and they were lower but still
significant and so we suspect that you
know it takes about three or four months
to to get rid of the effects of three
cycles so you know I think we envision
that this be a an option for you know
for doctors eventually to say yeah give
you drugs or maybe I could let the body
fix itself right and and see how far you
can go with this and then you know if
nothing nothing works then maybe we can
we can go to the drugs versus you know
gonna go into the drugs first and yeah
get to the root cause of what's
generating this in the first place as
opposed to putting a bandaid on it yeah
so this fasting monic mimicking diet
protocol that you've developed it
entails you know protocol in which you
have you know these foods and you're on
a very strict schedule and the idea is
that it allows you to eat rather than
just doing a water only fast but yet you
still garner the same benefits that you
would that you would experience if you
were just doing water so we it generated
out of looking at water fasts originally
that correct yes and no and you know we
suspect and we have data that we're
about to publish that is not just about
the lack it's also about what we have in
the FASTA making that right so
unfortunate I cannot talk about that but
it looks like there are multiple
components that we have selected that I
have actually positive effects I'll give
you one for example we have glycerol in
the end in the fast American diet in
glycerol turns out to be a byproduct of
fat but also is what's using
gluconeogenesis to make sugar when the
to feed the brain now if you don't have
glycerol the body breaks down muscle
right and so one of the observation in
the clinical trial
there was no or minimal loss of lean
body mass after three cycle the FMD and
we suspected for example grizzle is
playing that part I mean this is just
one of the 66 components that we have in
there and then and this is just I can
talk about that because we already
published that back but I think it's
gonna be a lot more than that and always
tall never trying to hack anything right
always sort of thinking in like in this
case what does the body make during
fasting glycerol okay then glycerin is
right so we're not trying to come up
with on the art version of so we now
have somebody in a fascist state that
has got glycerol but people in a fasted
state already have glycerin we just make
that higher right right I saw so that is
our thinking so it is what we call new
tree technology but it's a new
technology in tune with evolution a new
tree technology that really respects
where this is coming from understands
and respects it you know because for
example if you try to give and this is
silicon come out of Silicon Valley if
you try to give ketone bodies to
somebody this has a normal diet now you
could have a problem and I say this is
not in it they're not attempting to get
into a ketogenic state other than taking
exogenously eat oh yeah so now a lots of
people are doing that now
so you think about like a hybrid car
that is now you tweak it to work both on
electricity and on gasoline at the same
time right well as confusing it's gonna
break down unless you have an engineer
reprogramming it could do that but it
but the body is not meant to do that
it's be either fasting or it's not right
so now you have the sugar you put the
ketone bodies in there what's gonna
happen after five six seven years of
that I would strongly discourage people
from from doing ketone bodies during a
standard nutrition I mean nourishment
state right and why five days how did
you come up with five days as the window
well you need to break down right you
need to bleed glycogen and then you have
about three days where you you benefit
from break from now consuming only and
as we've shown in the clinical trial
this off fat right so the body now it
goes exclusive doesn't touch the
subcutaneous fat it goes after
the abdominal fat as its only a major
source of energy so now you suffer less
for the last three days you break down
the stem cells and are starting to get
activated and you have enough of a
window that you can start rebuilding if
you go much shorter it's never any
destruction there is never any cleaning
up and therefore there's gonna be
minimal rebuilding right and so and as
you get longer well if you go longer you
got now getting the danger zone right
you get in the compliance low compliance
on and danger zone right so now you need
to go to a clinic so five days after
over 30,000 people have done the prolong
diet we've seen very little side effects
there are there are there should be
reported and and so people can do it you
know they don't there's some people of
course struggle with it but most people
don't and yeah so I think compliance is
very important if people hate it and if
people feel it was too difficult they're
never gonna do it again and then you
know then it's drugs right so yeah
that's that's also in addition to the
specific nutrients that you spoke to
just by actually providing people with a
little bit of food enhances the the
compliance dramatically I would imagine
not just food but also the the selection
of food so we pick foods that for
example we have these nut bars and they
were designed to really fill you up so
it's a kind of fact that after a while
you're thinking okay that's it you know
I'm not hungry anymore it's not very
much but it's made in a way that it
really makes I mean people again it's a
a ton of food but it's it is doable and
and it's designed to try to make you as
full as possible mm-hmm
what about people that do do these
extended water fast like my friend ray
Crowe nice who's been in here I think he
does he's crazy like I think he's gone
like 45 days and I think there's
something powerful about that in that he
can sit here and
and and share his experience of that
that helps people like we were speaking
about earlier
snap out of this idea that we have to
eat three meals a day because somebody
decided that at some point but you know
I don't I don't know how healthy or
unhealthy that is it sounds like you
would be somebody who would say well
he's well into this danger zone or has
he acclimated to it because he's done it
a number of times and built up to that
or what's your perspective on that
well my perspective is that I mean he's
getting into the wall for its own right
so basically pushing the limits and and
there are reasons for not doing that
that we know of now for example Friday
there was a paper published on 15%
calorie restriction long term and what
happens it happens that your metabolism
now in people slaw past their loss of
weight so now their metabolism even
adjusted per weight per weight was lower
than it was before
so now after 45 days and it doesn't come
back up for a may not come back up for
years right so now if he does 45 days of
fasting all right now the body may have
no choice but to reduce the metabolism
to be as thrifty as possible now you
know this is why lots of people that go
to these clinics and do very long fast
usually the year after they come back
with the same weight that they had
before right so now you get into this
yo-yo and the question is and the
evidence seems to suggest that when you
go back now your metabolism is slower so
now you have a probably gonna have to
eat less then you used to eat before you
started this right all the time
otherwise you can I gain weight right so
that's another reason Emperor M and of
course the uncertainty what's gonna
happen after you do these 20 times
we don't know right more studies more
studies but roll group of food how many
people are gonna do that I know the the
booking allowed me clinic in Germany
they're starting to follow people they
do like three weeks you know so they're
trying to get as much information as
possible how many times if they done it
they have any problems so they'll be
interesting and I know there
TrueNorth clinic up in Northern
California I remember talking to them
and they were saying they were trying to
collect data on you know people that
have done it many times and and they've
had great results up there and I know a
bunch of those doctors they've they've
turned people's health around in
dramatic ways I don't know exactly what
their protocol is but water almost oh it
is water oh yeah in a clinic those fine
clinic you can do what supervisor
yeah it's medically supervised you've
nurses yeah in the same same in Germany
then then it's different you know
especially if you try to address some
some problem they know how to solve
mm-hmm I think it's important to point
out that what you're you're advocating
and suggesting is very different from
something else that's very popular right
now which is intermittent fasting this
idea of going I don't know 12 or 15
hours either every day or once a week or
I don't know how it breaks down for four
people but I would imagine that your
perspective on that would be that yeah
it's fine but in in maybe there's some
benefits to that but you're not doing it
long enough to really create this effect
that you're looking to produce
cellularly yeah well first of all I'm
just emailed the session panda the other
day because it's one of the guards and
NSA it's watch in 12 hours is really
intermedia you know it's done in
community this is what we've always done
right so I look how we call in that
inter minute facet that's crazy yeah so
but yeah people are doing that and the
problem with that is that we're starting
to use these words like carbohydrate you
know it's the same thing you know they
don't mean anything because if you eat
12 hours and that's what I point out in
the book if you eat for 12 hours that's
very good you know it's supported by the
five pillars stick stick to 12 hours
don't eat for 13 14 15 hours a day and
if you're overweight or obese eat twice
a day plus a snack and keep it 12 hours
that's the normal eating pattern is not
intermittent fasting right now
sixteen hours well no doubt that as it's
been shown you're gonna have benefits on
lost Excel Excel nobody talks about the
problem stuff problem number one ghost
'information
studies are showing that if you're
you're fast every day for more than 12
hours you now have an increased chance
that you're gonna need your gallbladder
removed not the worst thing it can
happen to you but not so not a nice
thing to happen to you and it gets to
about twofold increase in the risk of
all gallbladder operation number two
several studies showing if you skip
breakfast which most people will do if
you have 16 hours because most people
have dinner now you have increased
chance of cardiovascular disease cancer
and overall mortality is that well I I
skip breakfast all the time maybe is the
people to skip breakfast have a terrible
day center yeah we don't know I mean
it's not necessarily bad to skip
breakfast but it's certainly associated
with bad outcomes right people die
earlier not later earlier so then you
have to say yeah do you want to
recommend something that multiple
pillars are now are indicating to be
problematic right and and yeah so that's
why I mean first do no harm is a very
good advice right and this is what you
know people learn in the first year of
medical school so I think that we should
always start with that so first tune arm
is this associated with any problems and
if it is try to come up with something
else you know so twelve hours is great
timer City feeling such in it's worked
on that I've shown to be very beneficial
so if you think people that used to eat
for 14 hours a day 15 hours you reduce
it to 12 great because that's what the
centenarians do that's what every piece
of data is suggesting to be very good 16
hours not supported potentially entering
the the problem zone right that's that's
that's good to know I think that's
important information there's a lot of
people just launching into this world of
intermittent fasting without really
knowing what they're doing and I've
dipped my toe in it so you know it's
instructive to hear you say that one of
the things that I thought was
fascinating in reading your book in your
work was this idea that that the fasting
mimicking diet will have a well we'll
make healthy cells more resistant to
like if you have cancer right it will
make those cancer cells more susceptible
to the cancer treatments to the
chemotherapy and the healthier cells
strong so that they will be able to
withstand those treatments I didn't say
that very eloquently so yeah then they
like we had observed for bacteria and
yeast you take a normal cell at least in
a mouse and in the early data from
clinical studies is suggesting the same
we've shown already for white blood
cells for example from humans so if you
give them chemo the good cells know what
to do during starvation they become
protected they stop dividing or they
reduce growth rate and they enter a
protect amount the cancer cells by
definition by the way rebelled against
this they cannot they otherwise they
wouldn't be defined as a cancer cell so
one of the the all marks of cancer cells
is the ability to grow independently of
growth factor and to refuse anti-growth
signals so to rebel against theta
crossing so fasting is an anti growth
signal and the fasting and the cancer
cell rebound now you got a problem with
that and I use the analogy of imagine in
somebody running and desired in the
desert with a shade right and without
water now if you were running in the
desert like cancer cells do you know you
have shade and water you may make and so
if you have in the case of cancer cell
lots of growth factors lots of proteins
amino acids and sugar fine that's what
they've evolved in that unit literal as
soon as you start removing glucose and
removing growth factors and like igf-1
etc and adding anti growth factors now
the cancer cells are gonna have a
problem and that's what we see that's
why we see the fasting fasting that had
been as effective as chemo but
particularly with is working together
and that's where the Sun comes in right
the Sun is the chemo and so you know you
know
no water and you have the Sun hitting
you you're gonna be dead it's just a
matter of time right it's amazing how
that's worked out that it has the
desired effect on the cancer cells which
is to hopefully make them go away and at
the same time strengthening the healthy
cells it may I have now worked out and
maybe evolved right so we're starting to
suspect that think about sleep right so
you you sleep in and sleep is now there
by by mistake right it's forcing you to
rest for however many hours so we're
starting to think is it possible that
because all these organisms mostly state
yeast bacteria mostly they stay in a
starvation mode once in a while they
start eating right humans were not in
that situation but fasting was probably
so common that you didn't have to force
anybody to do it because they were
forced by the condition right so then
what if fasting was the moment where the
precancerous cells were getting killed
and and the and now you use it to
protect your cells in the moment of
starvation from the Sun from whatever
other you know problems and toxins you
might be exposed to so it may very well
be an adapted process where you're
starving protect your good cells protect
your genes and then get rid of cells
that are you know not functional anymore
also to eat him yeah yeah in the same
way that that exercise is good for you
right it's just something that we
evolved that we that we sort of
experienced in our evolution that
allowed us to you know weather hard
times and get stronger but we've moved
away from these things we're in a
culture in which we're just eating all
day long and we're sitting in chairs so
we we've moved away from these
evolutionary sort of mandates that that
keep us healthy yeah but yeah exercise
could be a little bit different exercise
is not really removing anything is more
damaging so exercise may have similar
effects for different reasoning that
when you let's say you have to run
excessively 20,000 years ago that
cause muscle damage and the response to
that maybe build Numa so because now
that tells you that you didn't have
enough right so it's a different concept
probably also leave there's sort of a
sort of a catabolic anabolic analogy and
that there's a breakdown and then
there's a rebuilding that makes you
stronger yeah yeah so it's a similar
idea but but the other mechanisms are
quite different because in exercise you
do damage and then you repair it right
rather than you get rid of it yourself
essentially but yeah the exercise I
think also uses some of the probably in
some cases the rebuilding my use as we
are seeing similar mechanisms right so
is it the rebuilding for exercise
probably doesn't quite go as extreme is
the rebuilding after prolonged fasting
but it may be using similar techniques
for example we know stem cells are
activated satellite stem cells muscle
stem cells are activated in response to
exercise mm-hmm what is the impact on
cognition of FMD yes so the in the mouse
there are very clear impact meaning that
they are cognitively sharper they
remember better they learn better
particularly when they're old and but
also when they're young but you see this
particularly when they're all now we're
doing we've done some special FM these
with mice on and off and Alzheimer's but
now we're doing the the human FMD we're
testing and now in my steeple Alzheimer
models and the idea is can we protect
the can we protect the brain against
Alzheimer even when we impose the human
mutation they cause Alzheimer's in a
hundred percent of the mice right so we
have some Mouse is called triple
transgenic and that's all these human
mutations they cause problems you know
this beta amyloid accumulation and tau
phosphorylated tau so yeah
so then hopefully within a year we'll
have the data on there and we're
starting a clinical trial we just got
funded by the Italian Ministry of Health
for a randomized clinical trial
Alzheimer's patients Wow the fasting
making diet so that would be very
interesting but particularly because
there is really nothing for dementia
right now and and so this would be
something that could be rapidly moved
into the into clinical use are you
familiar with Dean and I show shows a at
Loma Linda with their I forget I think
it's called the brain health unit they
they created a department there and
they're having some pretty tremendous
success working with early onset
Alzheimer's patients I had them on the
podcast they're doing really cool work
you know I'm collaborating with trans
Wong and and a few others that Melinda
but now with the brain people you should
meet these guys I'll connect you
is there anybody who who for whom the
fasting mimicking diet would not be
appropriate yes oh you know pregnant
woman wait below I think BMI 18.5 or
something like that people with diseases
they're gonna need the doctor or people
are taking drugs especially metabolic
drugs insulin particularly very
dangerous combination you can actually
die if you combine insulin and fasting
or fasting making diet yeah so I think
in general if somebody's healthy they
can talk to the nutritionist
and there is an expert in FMVs and they
will take him through but if somebody
has a disease they they need to run it
by the doctor and then the nutritionist
and the doctor can can work with them to
to see if it's doable right and the the
preferred the preferred protocol is to
do this five day program three times a
year like once a quarter four times a
year well depends right so if you
somebody who's at 32 year old athlete
that is Ana basket Aryan or a vegan diet
and it's you know everything is perfect
let's say you probably want to do it
twice a year and in somebody who's obese
it was got high cholesterol high blood
pressure maybe once a month until they
move to the lower category and then it
goes you know maybe once every four
months and then and then every yeah so I
say an average people should probably do
a 1 once every 4 months and then
depending on where they stand between
the 32 year old athlete and the OBE
right right I got ya I got you all right
well we got a we have to wind this down
but I have two questions but I can't let
you go without asking the first is if
somebody's listening to this or they're
watching this and they're
health-conscious they're interested in
taking care of themselves but this is
brand-new information they never heard
anything like this before you know
what's the what's the thing that you
want people to bear in mind that they
might that might not be self-evident to
the average consumer about how they
approach their their day their diet
their lifestyle habits well I'm I mean
you know I I have a list at the end of
the chapter for heading in the book and
and there's ten things that I think
people all should do they're not very
hard and and of course you know
different people will get to different
levels of it you know so for example
what we talked about early the 12 hour
limit you know you do 15 hours and I say
twelve and you can get to 13 well you
know at least you're close you know and
and that's that's the idea try to get as
close as possible to all these
recommendations because they're really
based on five pillars I mean my opinion
is in there but not very much I mean
it's more like a systematic way of
looking at this including our history
you know where do we come from
not just systematic in Silicon Valley a
way of you know trying to hack
everything but more like you know let's
combine that hacking with with our
history and where we come from you know
to make sure that we stay in tune with
the
right that's a great answer and if you
were to wake up and find yourself to be
the Surgeon General the United States
what would be your primary first policy
initiative like what needs to change in
our health care system yeah so I get
fired within it somebody tell me that
everybody you ask every doctor that
comes on the show the same question they
I mean every one of them will get fired
but it's funny because I believe that
the Surgeon General went they when 50
years ago say smoking is bad for you and
he was fired for the same yeah so I
think we were sure these five meals a
day is a bad idea it's it's a company
this obesity epidemic in the United
States and around the world you know
when you have seven 70% of people in the
US that are either obese or overweight
and you still recommend eating five
times a day it's entertaining to me that
they don't understand that what could
work in a clinic you know so if you
brought somebody into a clinic as we do
when you keep him there then they could
it could actually work but if you tell
somebody eat five times a day then what
happens is that you start eating more
and they eat for fifteen sixteen hours a
day they're not eating a banana and some
almonds they're going to Cheesecake
Factory
yeah so they're they're eating the bad
food and they're eating four more meals
longer time so the combination of these
two I think is the bad food more minos
longer time the three things are really
detrimental so I would say if you can go
to either a vegan or vegan pescetarian
diet and keep it within 12 hours and
keep it to if you're overweight if you
one of the seven out of ten Americans
are overweight keep it at two meals a
day plus a snack so let's say you have
breakfast lunch and a snack for dinner
or breakfast a snack for lunch and
dinner mmm I mean this thing could be a
hundred calorie low sugar you know like
a salad or something like it
it's a pleasure talking to you dr. long
ago like I think your your work is
groundbreaking the work you're doing is
inspirational I think we're going to be
seeing and hearing from you quite a bit
more your book the longevity diet is
groundbreaking and I wish you only the
best as you continue to do more research
and it's an honor and a privilege to
help you get your message out into the
world so thank you for your time today
if you're interested in vaulter and his
work pick up his book the longevity diet
if you're interested in learning more
about the fasting mimicking diet you can
go to pro lawn FMD calm and they have
all the information there you have these
kits that you can order I think it's
important to say that vaulter himself
does not profit individually off of this
whatsoever all the money that he earns
from this goes directly into funding
research with what's the organization
called via cures that are and what and
what is create you're still okay Akira
is a foundation that I started with the
idea you know I had like every day I
have ten cancer patient or people
without two immunities and whatever or
disease and they're like desperate and
you know I realized that doesn't matter
who you are whether you're poor or rich
there is really very little out there
that helps you with in a you know in a
serious way and say okay you have cancer
I mean there's a lot of quackery out
there but it's not to too many people
order than the oncology that tells you
here the drugs we're gonna give you then
people were faced with internet good
luck to you you know and so Creek here
is really about what can somebody do
today not twenty years from now but
today that is gonna make their therapy
more effective it's gonna make the
side-effects lower so it's gonna help
them and in on some cases we lap down
the clinical studies in some cases we
haven't but the patient cannot wait and
so we sort of have to act now and that
we felt as important we're doing it all
over the world now with many many
different hospitals and we're starting
to see you know the doctors slowly being
you know converted into understanding
this this difficult situation where you
can now wait you cannot tell somebody
who stage four breast cancer for whom
you know therapy's not working oh you
know these guys in ten years are gonna
have something for you you know right
exactly
fantastic thank you all right thing and
your your you're not on Twitter right
welp Roland's on Twitter promo on FMD no
I have a Facebook profile too long ago
Facebook page where we put just articles
about you know anybody that we feel we
sort of have a couple nutritionists and
dietitian screening papers and if we
feel something is good you know then
we'll pull out there and and and we're
usually associated with like article
from a newspaper that describes what it
is cool so I'll link that up in the show
notes and are you did you ever like get
up in front of public audiences to talk
yes yes I do that from time to time and
yeah so is there any where where do we
now so Facebook we do a Facebook live
maybe once every couple months off just
so people can you know ask question
right and and login and ex questions all
right thanks
[Music]